foreign
the Avatar sequel Avatar 2 the way of
water was released this past weekend 13
years after the original came out 12 and
a half years after everyone forgot that
the original ever existed it was a brief
moment in time when millions of people
were somehow duped into believing that
Avatar was a good film but the fever
broke rather suddenly most of those who
had fallen under its spell quickly
realized the whole thing was just Fern
Gully as reimagined by the Blue Man
Group not exactly a plot twist therefore
to tell you that the sequel fizzled at
the box office on its first weekend of
release it fizzled with 134 million
dollars over the weekend
to be precise which seems like a lot of
money to qualify as a flop Until you
realize that they spent a billion
dollars making this thing and Port
hundreds of millions into marketing so
that anything less than a historic box
office Hall would be a disappointment
and in this case the movie fell under
even the most modest projections
now I for one am quite pleased with with
this result
um I like it when bad movies perform
poorly and this is a bad movie it may
have impressive special effects but then
there really isn't anything that is
actually impressive about special
effects anymore I'll never understand
people these days who are impressed like
well a great special effects so what if
you have a billion dollars to make a
movie we expect that the CGI will be top
of the line that's like that's just
basic level stuff
what matters is the story and if the
first avatar was a rehash of what a
dozen other films had already done and
done better than Avatar 2 is a rehash of
a rehash
there's nothing new about this kind of
cynical recycling of course but it's
always worse coming from James Cameron
because although
he hasn't had an original idea in like
30 years he still considers himself to
be a genius Storyteller and so both the
first Avatar and this reheated version
are epically absurdly long like this
one's almost three and a half hours long
as Cameron indulges every narcissistic
showy impulse refusing to cut a single
scene or a single line of dialogue
Because he believes that the entire
thing is a Work of Staggering Genius
even though it's literally just
Pocahontas but not as good
on top of that Cameron happens to be one
of the wokest directors currently
working in Hollywood Avatar is of course
an environmentalism allegory about the
Perils of colonialism it's not my
interpretation that's what he says it is
and if the wokeness wasn't clear enough
Cameron's been out on the trail
promoting the film by ranting against
the evils of testosterone as we covered
in a recent daily cancellation he
claimed that testosterone is a poison
that must be purged from the bloodstream
and then on Friday an interview with
variety he bragged that Avatar is
setting a new standard for female
empowerment because it features a
pregnant female Warrior it's one of the
daily wire says director James Cameron
said in a recent interview that his
upcoming movie Avatar the way of water
is the most empowering movie for women
because one of the characters is a
pregnant Warrior the movie which uh
debuted in theaters across the us on
Friday continues where the first movie
left off uh and in this film one of the
main characters Knight tiri is pregnant
Cameron made the remarks about niteria
during an interview with variety when he
was asked why it was important to have
niteria and another character be
pregnant in the movie
he said Well everybody's always talking
about female empowerment but what is
such a big part of a woman's life that
we as men don't experience and I thought
well if you're really going to go all
the way down the rabbit hole of female
empowerment let's have a Female warrior
who's six months pregnant in battle I
thought let's take the real boundaries
off to me it was the last Bastion That
You Don't See Wonder Woman and Captain
Marvel all these other amazing women
come up but they're not moms and they're
not pregnant while they're fighting evil
yes he's gone down the rabbit hole of
female empowerment
is this really all the way down the
rabbit hole what about a pregnant female
in a wheelchair in battle
how about a pregnant blind trans woman
with one leg epilepsy and a diagnosed
anxiety disorder in battle
now it's not clear how
any of this actually would be empowering
in fact it's not clear how the exploits
of a fictional character in a CGI
Universe could ever Empower anyone
regardless pregnant or not but this is
what empowerment has become
for the record you know even if this is
a fictional Universe there is actually
nothing empowering about sending
pregnant women off to fight battles a
truly empowered pregnant woman is going
to prioritize protecting her unborn
child and therefore is not going to put
herself in a situation where both she
and the child are very likely to be hurt
but this is this is the Hollywood idea
of empowerment
the empowered person is the person who
acts like anything other than what they
are
the person who rejects their fundamental
duties and responsibilities the
empowered woman is then the woman who
acts like a man while the empowered man
is the man who acts like a woman
this is the empowerment they sell us
which is empowerment turned on its head
it's the opposite of empowerment
which is the essence of wokeness
everything is the opposite of what it
ought to be
and yet
even with all this effort to be woke
the film still is not woke enough here's
the headline from Newsweek Avatar faces
calls for boycott over accusations of
racism
the article then explains director James
Cameron is facing allegations of Native
American and Indigenous cultural
appropriation over the themes and
imagery in his latest Blockbuster Avatar
the way of water like his predecessor
the sequel centers on a story about
colonizers taking over land from tribes
and Cameron's telling the colonizers are
humans who need a new inhabitable Planet
because Earth's resources are becoming
increasingly depleted also like its
predecessor the new Avatar film is being
accused of using an amalgamation of
histories of various indigenous cultures
for a film that features a largely white
cast among those upset by Cameron's film
is you be gay a Native American
influencer and co-chair of indigenous
Pride la
do not watch Avatar the way of water be
gay wrote on Twitter on Sunday join
Natives and other indigenous groups
around the world and boycotting this
horrible and racist film
be gay also said that indigenous
cultures were appropriated in a harmful
manner to satisfy a white man's quote
savior complex another Twitter user
whose critiques of Avatar have gained
attention is Autumn Asher Blackbeard an
assistant professor in The Graduate
School of Social Work at the University
of Denver why watch a movie about blue
aliens when you could just support
actual indigenous people and our
struggle for clean water here on Earth
yes we do exist black deer wrote she
followed up with a thread listing sci-fi
films made by indigenous people
so that's right Avatar commits
appropriation
they do have a point I mean after all
James Cameron
he does cast mostly white actors to
portray people of color in the film now
it's true the color of the people in
this case is blue
and they're not even people but uh
that's irrelevant he could have he could
have at least here's all I'm saying he
could have made the effort to try to
travel to another solar system and find
actual blue aliens to fill these roles
you could have tried didn't even try it
steady just took the easy way out put
actors in blue face instead
now the criticism here is obviously
ridiculous
what's more they're attacking James
Cameron for somehow negating or
minimizing the struggles of quote
indigenous people when the entire movie
is one long overly simplistic childish
retelling of the settlement of the new
world wherein white man bad native
people good
exactly the version of history that
these activists want us to accept they
demand that we accept it
and James Cameron has spent billions of
dollars creating not one but two pieces
of overwrought propaganda to deliver
just that message
and they're still mad
that's how it works
of course the game is rigged especially
if you're a white man
the woker Never Satisfied whatever you
do it will not be enough
whatever you do you should have done
something else
the woke are never happy
they make demands that cannot be
satisfied
that's because they don't want to be
satisfied
they just want the demands they don't
want the satisfaction of those demands
they want the demands
trying to please them then is a Fool's
errand and James Cameron James Cameron
is just that sort of fool which is why
he is canceled for I think like the
second time in a week
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show is move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow God Speak
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]